club and now we are gonna learn about
sports networks estimations
because I'm very last speaker I think
I think is there was
[Applause]
a lot
okay so my talk is about sparse
of course and other speakers I learned a
lot
we discussed if some colleagues with
this like a receptional speakers because
it was very easy to follow even in
topics which we're not really working in
some people really have made an effort
to
to learn us something it was really
great
okay so my talk is about sparse Network
estimation and first of all so it's
based on civil work uh joint with such a
tobacco of Nicolas and my PhD students
language
and as we had many talks and like
different topics uh where we have crafts
crafts limited graph phones just to fix
the ideas my talk is will be uh so from
statistical point of view we observe a
network person with networks comes from
a from a model which means with the
realization of running graph model and
we want to learn something about this
unknown
model particular parameter if we run
parametric parametric model or something
else so we also what I'll discuss is
model based statistical analysis of
Networks
okay and so uh it is like very important
line of Works uh in statistic uh which
is trying to fit what we're observe in
practice the the real life networks
remodel
I'm interested in this question and so
uh I'm also in parametric models are
probably the most popular uh has
affected a lot of attention at least in
machine learning and statistical
communities is with stochastic block
model right you I said with everyone is
familiar with it and just to fix the
notations that I will need um
our results so we have n nodes where
partitioning K groups
and then uh uh so each node is
associated to a community so uh so
Community Z of I
so that will be the index function here
and then uh this this parameter this
index function either we can see it as a
parameter to be estimated so we want to
learn the communities of which node
either it can it can be viewed as a
latent variable
so that I've used two approaches to to
the model and so on top of this index
function we have a matrix queue so this
is semantic K times scheme Matrix which
provide us um the Inter-Community age
probabilities right
so if mathematics to vertices uh
uh are connected to probability q i j
which depends on the communities
and so so there are different reasons
why uh this model is very popular of
course it's easy to easy to study right
um
um the smallest popular because it
allows saturated graphs with community
structure and many real real life
networks uh have community structure but
also probably with some more more more
fundamental reasons because oh well um
it can be like a very good basic
approximation units for more complex
models so it's quite standard
um
approaching statistics so I have my data
probably the three models very very
complex but that approximate it for
something easier and that probably I can
make good predictions on something very
quite reasonable from this simple
approximation like linear regression
so uh this is somehow justify why
stochastic block model is so popular in
statistics
uh and so uh what I'll consider and we
can also consider a slightly more
General model in homogeneous random
graph model where we observe an
adjacency Matrix right and then we
assume that um each aij is a Bernoulli
random variable with parameter Theta IJ
and then we have minus 3 to 0 which
contains uh i j and so this is the
Matrix of probabilities Associated to
the graph
and um
so web server graph we observe the
gcmatics and what we will want to learn
or estimate is uh with Matrix ft zero
with Matrix of connection probabilities
right uh um so in statistics we are
mostly interested in the sparse case why
because real life networks via sparse
right and for this information is random
graph model uh there are different ways
to Define sparsity there is this one
which is uh used to load in the
literature but I assuming with the super
Norm of Matrix ft is zero goes to zero
one n goes to Infinity uh this uh forces
kind of
it's part of quite homogeneous right for
instance we're not getting hubs and so
on but our other way of defining Parts
in this model but maybe more more
adequate but for for this talker um I
will use this definition which is quite
common but many of stuff that I'll I'll
present can be extended to more general
definition of sparse
I'm interested in a very basic
statistical question I have a single
observation of my graph a single
observation Matrix a and I want to
estimate this Matrix three to zero
previous single observation
right and so uh as uh we asked this in
statistics one of the important
questions is is a question of Minimax
rate of convergence
so if you heard already talk some
statistics probably you you you're
hosting already what is what is it so
why they are important in statistics and
so uh the Minimax uh optimal rate is
convergency is the best rate with any
estimator any method can achieve and the
problem of estimation that we are
looking at
hence usually also how how to define
this Minimax rate so we take the
infamous over all possible estimators or
all possible algorithms
and we take supremum over all possible
parameters so here for instance this is
all matrices uh for stochastic block
model uh with K communities and sparse
Stereo One
and then we're interested uh
the behavior of risk of an estimator and
then of course we need to choose a
metric to measure the risk of our
estimator here the result uh is an
intravenous Norm
and so um in the formula's norm uh the
the Minimax rate of convergency for this
problem are node
for stochastic block model uh so here
you have two parts
and actually the interesting part is
only this one
why because um this part row and square
corresponds to a very sparse case when
rho 1 is
smaller than one over n and this is the
case but we know that the null estimator
which means that zero Matrix is Minimax
optimal so this case is not interesting
because I put everything to be equal to
zero and I'm optimal so nothing to do in
this case this
okay as a result hold only when rho n is
going to zero I'm sorry does it result
hold only when row N is going to zero
sure yeah so here row when the
it's a decimal one depends on N so even
in the
even ruins the constant the still the
variance is going to zero right
yeah sure yeah yeah so Row one constant
in this case
sure but it's normalized right
and so
um this is straight from sparse case it
depends on the role when
so uh you why are you not dividing by
rho n
like if there's Parts why is it 1 over N
squared
you meet the risk yeah yeah
wow you can divide but over when just
and the other way to write it but this
is the minimum something like the rate
of conversions before this class of
management I fixed through when I fix k
inside
I think it probably means parallel x
squared because Square Norm but if you
divide by over one square you just get
log K over row times n yeah through well
depends on N right right it goes to zero
which means are divided by something
goes to Infinity my risk yeah it's just
that I would if we would expect end
times sorry N squared minus n times rho
n to be 0 anyway
right in The Matrix
no I'm just saying we would expect uh
the only n time n choose two times row
and many edges so N squared row and
edges
square of N squared times rho n edges
where
order N squared ruin edges
suppose we would just estimate it by
zero what would our error be
zero that's basically your question
just zero this is the year
with dominating and the key from the
rule when it's smaller we could one over
n this is what it cannot deal with uh so
the first term this is
the first term describes how much better
you can do compared to estimating by
zero
comparing to zero but this is the best
what they can achieve in this program we
cannot beat it
the income over all possible estimation
methods in fact we cannot do better for
this problem
and actually it's not that bad
let me explain a little bit more so uh
as it's not mentioned row only cooked
one uh corresponds to the dense case
right and this what actually was
difficult to get this right dependency
in real way because we if you deal with
dense case actually it's not that
difficult
the proof illustrate but
to get a good dependency ruin those
non-trivial but if if
Fusion is people don't understand your
Twitter your Twitter means bounded above
and below by a constant no no no no
your Twitter in this equation
seta off yeah two constants which are
independent of Rowan n and K such that
okay and now if people want to divide
each side by or end they are welcome to
do that okay
I got it yeah so this means this means
that we have like finite sample upper
body and find a simple lower bound and
two constants which are independable
Dimensions whatever you can divide by
row okay thank you thank you
okay so let me somehow elaborate on the
rate and so um if if we if we suppose
we're drawing is equal to one that means
with an advanced case uh the result has
been obtained before uh so in this very
nice paper by GAO and quarters and so as
I mentioned survey so in this case it
will be there very this one right and it
has two parts
right actually each one of the support
part uh part each one of these parts
it's quite easy to understand so the
first one is called it's like it's a
really classical no parameter creative
statistics why I see what we knowable
labels right if we know variables the
only thing we need to estimate is with
with Q times Q Matrix
Matrix Q right we have K Square
parameters to be estimated
right and now we observe our GC
semantics which is n Square so a number
of generations proportional to n Square
so number of parameters to be estimated
divided by the number of observations
this is why it's classical
non-parametric rate but we don't know
the labels and this is why we have this
clustering rate so we have n nodes
and I need to to label them with key
communities I have K to power n
possibilities and this is exactly the
log of K to power n divided Again by the
number of observations which is
proportional to n Square so both rates
were by quite easy to understand
non-parametric rate which comes from
estimation of Matrix Q
and clustering rate which comes from
from the fact that we don't know bullets
and
and with trikishin was somehow get the
good dependence on sparsity because one
cinematic response like
where one goes to zero and so uh
right like this it's not meaningful
right
okay so good so we have this uh Minimax
rate of convergency
which uh
now in your min max given how this is
set up you could use examples that a
matrix which has one entry or 4N and all
other zero so what if instead you would
Define row N as average enter of your
Matrix instead of the largest one maybe
plus some assumptions that's the largest
one is not too much larger but you get
better rates as I mentioned actually
probably it's not the optimal way to
find this vercities and currently your
your question yes so I wonder if you
define suppository different could you
get better min max rates yeah for
instance one way but I think it's better
for this problem we take the what uh
L1 Infinity Norm like the super Norm of
L1 Norms of columns divided by n
so ask this goes to zero this is another
way to find sparsity everything will go
through that's a maximal degree
it's like it allows you to to not be two
emissions between the nodes but when
everything will go through and so uh
we'll get the same the same rates so I
think
they are good trades and of course they
they depend on the norm
so they are known for provincial for cat
Norm to cut non-verbed news the
anti-symmetics is already Minimax
optimal uh but then of course we can
think about other norms and probably
somehow
this is for frabino storm and the master
to conversation also known for the
cardinal
okay but I agree with uh this this
notion of sparsity profits not the ideal
one personally prefer reviews one sounds
I think we'll get the same yeah I didn't
try really each line
oh I'm quite I'm quite convinced
only thing is I'm sure with upper bound
to do the same I never tried to to to
lower bound but the lower bound
essentially is the same it's a student's
case
and so this person doesn't really play a
role where so I think it's like say cut
my head it's not true but I'm 90 sure of
it it's the same thing
right
okay so uh oh this is nice but um
so we want to estimate the Matrix right
and so we want the method which which
allows us to mathematics and the bad
news here is that with optimal rate can
be achieved by the least Square
estimator and that means that we need to
minimize over all possible labelings
which means so we have K to power n
possibilities and the the algorithm will
scale uh exponentially in the end and we
don't want sorry for interrupting you
again but if I remember your paper
correctly it was not quite least Square
you had to do some thing with knowing
the largest entry of the Matrix or
something uh argument indeed we needed
to know them
yes but um
it doesn't change the the minimum
straight
because we fixed the class before Oh you
now know your point okay if you don't
know Roy and then it's a different view
well actually no because I'll show more
recent results where you don't need to
know ruin and you can be Minimax optimal
so it's it's not so you so now you know
that the standard
at least Square without this constraint
is Stillman Max Optima no I don't know
of it I know but variation approximation
to the Emily is
much better because it can
I never tried the least squares but as
we tried very hard with Sasha and Nicola
I don't want to go through it again
uh okay so the problem is that we cannot
compute the least squares because it's
an exponential in number of nodes and so
okay and so uh so the next question was
so what can be achieved in polynomial
time so what can be done in practice and
actually for quite a long time uh we
believed uh that
um
actually this is one of the cases when
we have what's called uh polynomial
computational gap for this problem which
means that the Minimax uh Optical rate
of convergency cannot be achieved by the
polynomial time algorithm and so when
this next question was what can be done
at minimum time
uh and so uh for instance uh one option
is to use the hard to hold an estimator
at uh uh it's actually hard to run
estimator it's it's really related to
them
the universal singular value estimator
by chitoshi except that we can improve
his rates
uh by uh substantially and so
essentially if you go for a similar
estimator uh we'll get K Over N rate so
when K Over N rate which is not that bad
at least uh in this
and we said in which trees in the book
usually we have some K small right so
with quite simple estimator we can get
essentially quite optimal so we replace
low K by K
yeah sure yeah it's it's really
Universal singular but soft except with
um
fixed fixed the thresholder uh so you
take registered systematics
you take a van
singular variety of the preposition
right
if in stochastic block model we at most
rank K right and then uh so uh we are
doing a hard threshold but Smith will
cut
only keep
um they have singular values and with
this composition which are larger with
something which is not other thing but
the the spectral Norm of the ear so just
a spectral Norm or centered Bernoulli
random Matrix
so you need to cut on the level of a
noise measured in the spectral norm and
then we can prove that the rate which
we'll get is
actually uh
this is not surprising because this is
the rate for low rank Matrix estimation
actually illustrate except for row N
which is difficult to get
because for low rankmatic estimation
you'll get the variance of the noise
and here um he essentially problem comes
from them from the from Bernoulli noise
with the difference between the variance
and the psy to normal
one that scares like Row one and the
other local one so difficult to go from
block row and to Rowan but uh
can be done still
it's
close to Optimal one of the gyms not uh
in all the regimes and um
so uh
we forward like
fine to find something something better
and like the natural candidate and
statistic at least is the maximum
likelihood estimator right we don't know
what to do right so let's try maximum
food estimator
uh and actually this is so natural
statistics are they maximum likelihood
estimator for the stochastic block model
or in homogeneous random ground model
that has been studied in several papers
and this is not really not exhaustive
list of of works on that
the estimator will be also and be hard
because we still have this problem of uh
maximizing over all the labels but what
is good about maximum likelihood
estimator might make it different
comparatively squares uh there are
computational efficient approximations
to this method that has been
proportionally literature and in
different different
propositions serve the likelihood method
variation approximation and we are
really successful in practice people
really use them with approximation and
and got some interesting results
so next next question uh given that it's
quite successful and uh we have this
approximation is the Minimax and maximum
likelihood Minimax optimal
and actually uh yes sponsor is yes we
can prove um
an upper bound
which match the lower bound
uh with uh
slightly more restrictive condition
actually uh the result is
slightly worse the fully squares why
because we have a constant
which will depend on the upper bound and
the lower bound of the super Norm of the
Matrix and so it will be Minimax optimal
only when uh the upper lower bound they
have the same order and if if not we can
have exact formula for this constant to
know how it will iterate the rate
but isn't that more or less a problem
you just we know for maximum likelihood
estimators because if you for example if
you had a bipartite graph you have some
probability zero and the maximum
likelihood will just never work because
you divide somewhere by zero so it seems
that having problems when your thing is
too near to zero seems inherent for
maximum likelihood
yeah yeah this is because like we have
as if there's your least Square doesn't
have this problem right yeah because we
have log right right between some lips
condition on that to go from block from
likelihood to the Rubino's Norm we need
pictures condition and this is how we
get this constant hey I agree but the
good news is that uh
we can prove for an approximation of a
maximum likelihood that it is also
Minimax optimal and where we don't need
this condition on the on the smallest
probability of connection
we can get rid of this condition for
approximation of this method
so maximum likelihood at least what we
we proved
it was a
Minimax optimal rate times a term
which depends on both row and gamma
gamma and lower bound I can write it
essentially
um gamma and square over one square
essentially okay so it's so it will
Minimax optimal only when um
uh by the way out right
it will be minimaxed up to only one um
this layer of the same order
but still for for a class of matrices
minimum maximum likelihood is Minimax
optimal
it's
okay
um but um
non-computationally feasible still
cannot use it in practice
and so actually uh the solution to this
problem of
maximum likelihood estimator on
but we cannot complete in practice it's
quite well known so it goes through
variational approximation and in the
first day of a workshop we had very nice
talk uh
uh
by subham Braddock who introduced
vibration approximation
and so I just do somehow recap what he
he told and so uh what is variation
approximation variation approximation is
this is with techniques which comes from
patient statistics right
uh which allows us to approximate the
Pastoral distribution essentially the
first place why do we need to
approximate uh um repository
distribution
uh because so in statistic we assume the
data comes from a model this model uh
usually uh have unknown parameters and
they also may have latent variables like
here like the variables
and uh the usual approach Invasion
statistic let's put it prior on the
unknown parameters and then let let
write the posterior distribution so
distribution of this unknown parameters
given the data but the the bad news is
that often we'll end up with hard to
solve integrals
okay and so we have this hard to solve
integrals or optimization problem is
here but we cannot solve and so uh the
idea which comes from physics I think is
okay I have this this thing but I cannot
compute there is no analytical solution
let's approximate it by something
simpler
and uh this is called variation
approximation and as we are using
approximation we need to somehow measure
how good we fit where to post a story to
this approximation and the usual choice
is the quebecue library diversionship
it's still often we end up with
something that's quite difficult to
compute or there is no like exact
analytical solution and then uh the next
simpleplification is okay let us see
with um
the distribution with which I will
approximate my my posterior can be
written as kind of product right so I
assume that uh with unknown variables it
can be somehow partitioned in a way with
each partition is independent and with
this additional like simplification uh
then it is known as the mean field
approximation
and after
all these approximations actually why
people are doing that we often um
end up with something which can be
computed
at least going from some interactive
algorithms right and just to put it in
perspective when we have this posterior
distribution that we cannot somehow talk
about the integrals either we do this
variation approximation either mcmc
which can put slow with compound
estimate with posterior so this is one
of one of two options it's usually um
uh people use
the
previous
slide I guess I'm just missing something
oh no I'm sorry the next Slide the K to
the end so why can't one first find the
communities and then estimate you know
what is this K to the end
this is all possible labelence
can one come up with some separate uh
pipeline which first estimates the
community is reasonably well using the
graph topology and then yeah well at
least um
so the only like
results that I know in community
detection which provide us like quite
strong guarantees and Community
detection which allows us to ensure that
we are Minimax optimal they they
restricted to very strict cases to have
stochastic block model with two
Community
associate certificates and so on I'm not
worried of any from the detection method
which works in quite general setting
with good guarantees
so I cannot recover communities but I
need to guarantee on what I recovered if
not I am not Mini Max optimal profit
zero you know my main motivation like to
answer this question is web
computational Gap so I want to find the
algorithm which is computational and
Minimax optimal for estimation fee to
zero okay so for sure I can do it for
some simple models like to to block
stochastic block model as a certificate
blah blah blah same probabilities
between all the communities
I mean I would imagine if the degree n
times rho n goes to infinity and you
have like rank k or something then
somehow there is some I would have
imagined but presumably you can that's
why you need all this but I just
so one comment is I think she also needs
it for K changing with n right
so most of the classical music
but I think you are allowing for the
possibility where K is D possibly
dependent on N so the the constants in
your Minimax result do not depend on
either K or n and the classical results
are mostly for fixed K as far as I
understand so I think that's that's okay
because uh
so it's it's my in my uh in my set okay
it was fixed but uh you know I think
this result also applies if k k scan if
I remember Charles paper correctly but
yeah I can I can grow effect
yeah right
we have no idea how to put
it
is always in behind but this spectral
estimators are not uh
um
okay so just um just to finish with this
recap so fine we we don't know how to
compute our estimator later approximated
so we can solve it but what is about the
statistical guarantees probably what
we'll get uh in the end of the day but
very far away from the true parameters
and the main point of of
um super great talks was that
we think that in many situations
actually uh variation approximation will
get will will be it's called accurate
which means that we'll end up in the
ball of radius Epsilon n with Epsilon n
which equals to zero and uh he he
presented his result for linear
regression and if I need to resume my
talk in one Trace special I ran off time
is that with meaningful approximation
Works exceptionally well with stochastic
block model
it's not only like accurate but Minimax
optimal which is quite exceptional
because people use a lot of pressure
approximation but there is not that much
a study of with security except some
some specific models in particular for
stochastic lock mode okay of course
we are not the first who discovered it
with fresh approximation works pretty
well in this situation
um so I think first time but the
proposed kind of operational
approximation was on my paper by the Dan
and collectors and then these two papers
are provided something quite strong
guarantees on it they provided normality
so cities and quarters through dense
case and begin helicopters for their
sparse case
and so we know that um
so we have a stick normality uh for
variational approximation to Emily and
actually people also use it for
Community detection so there are some
methods based on variation approximation
Community protection
and what we proved to Solan is that uh
on top of this what is known it's
optimal from a statistical point of view
estimated between we are able to compute
will be Minimax optimal and we don't
need to know upper bound low bound
whatever and what was like byproduct was
not targeting it but actually it also
achieved under the conditions under
which the model is identifiable the
perfect recovery of labels and this is a
quite general setting so we're just so
people using practice but and they are
right to use it because on top of being
Minimax optimal it allows to recover the
exact labels on the condition under
which the models is in the department
very good and so um
let me spend five minutes just to
explain a little bit more can I okay so
um
first of all as we're going through
inspirational approximation uh we need
to put it prior
and so uh so the stochastic block model
is I presented it in the beginning it's
usually called conditional stochastic
book model right where we assume that
labels are fixed but the complete
stochastic look model we assume that
this labels becomes from distribution
right from a multinomial distribution
with perimeter Alpha
so the prayer on that
and so now we end up with stochastic
block model of two parameters the same
Matrix Q as before and now uh the
probabilities of belonging to each
community so this is the vector of K
numbers which uh one I I pick a vector
when I assign a community for this
Vector so I'll assigned uh my node to
communicate I with probability Alpha I
so this provides probability to be in
the community I
you have a fight on K as well
no kids fixed
no pressure
okay and so then uh we can write
okay
no
and so we can write the complete
likelihood here for this model right
still summation over all possible
labelings can be hard and so we'll use
mean field approximation
and here what does it mean it means that
I'll approximate the posterior
distribution of my labelings by just by
product of multinomial distribution like
really like
um
it's really like Brute Force right like
just everything is independent it's
let's put it in this way okay and so um
and this approximation introduced me new
perimeter Tau right which contains these
parameters for this multinomials
uh in my approximation
okay and so um
what I'll do so I cannot
maximize the true likelihood and be hard
so I'll
maximize the approximation which is a
lower bound why because uh this is Mrs
be true likelihood this is the major
how well approximate the posterior with
my so let's measure how how far away is
the trooper stereo from approximation
and there's a cool back labor is
non-negative this is a lower bar so I
have a function but I cannot maximize
let's try to maximize the lower bound
open with the maximum of the somehow
close
okay uh because I'm not having much time
still we have something like
we maximize number three different
parameters
like high dimensions and so usual way
how people uh do it in practice they use
kind of iterative algorithms so let's
fix two of these three parameters
learn the third one and when we launched
the third one we sorry we iterate and
this is called expectation maximization
algorithm by the standard and statistics
so it's iterative hopefully it's collage
and uh so what so so
everything that is still this point is
like was in the literature before us
um
what was not in particular from these
two papers
known with maximize is equivalent to
maximizing the true likelihood which is
good right
uh what is also known that the
estimators who were I'll find you
uh from from this approximation will
converge to three parameters
but um there is no guarantees on the
recovery for True labels
and but so but actually once we we uh
computed this operational approximation
right
we got Alpha and Q but we go also got
this town which approximates the
Pastoral of the labels so uh why don't
use this this approximation to a
posterior for classifying the labels and
so this is what we did right just take
the maximum probability
to the community with a maximum
probability from this approximation the
true posterior
and once um we have this label a list of
estimator for the labels
actually what we did we replace uh the
estimator
chromatic's Q which comes from
validation approximation by just the
empirical mean
and this uh notifications allows us to
get an estimator for Q to Theta which
will be um Minimax option so we need
this modification of this trick
password empirical mean to be Minimax
optimal
okay uh this is the result
we um
would be very sparse we need to drop it
yes we should
so you know in general I guess uh you
know the variational approximation may
or may not have a unique Global
maximizer right for example even in the
context of linear regression unless you
assume something it does not have a
unique maximize a global one so in your
setting is there a unique Global one
so first of all it's not for the
solution of an algorithm for expectation
minimization it's really fully solution
of evaluation estimator yeah and with
the same any point would you maximize my
objective function will satisfy with
these conditions so you do not impose
conditions which guarantee uniqueness of
the units of the global maximizer of one
no but somehow all the over Maximum do
close
so do you have examples in simulations
where you have do you suspect that in
this problem there is a unique maximizer
or do you suspect that there are
multiple Global maximizers in one
oh this is hard question we can talk
later offline that's uh yeah but somehow
what does it mean it means that even if
we have multiple uh maximum that we're
all quite close okay
so so we get exactly right but we wish
under some conditions and actually with
conditions it comes from the paper by
big helicopters the guarantees with the
models
identifiables are not identifiable but
you cannot identify variables so we
cannot cannot uh estimate myself
and um so we not only have that um
so our Tomatoes Minimax optimal
example I I missed the result
yeah
what's the proof that we achieve the
exact recovery for labels
recovery labels I mean surprised that I
forgot to put it on the slide
it depends on the Matrix yes
but it's constant when this certain yeah
that doesn't depend on the wrong way
something
yes sir so you need much much larger
than logic
so that situation no it could be log log
of it
just large it's like could be
any logs
but you need you don't have uniformity
it's a technology might have to be
throw away
you mean custom sparsity
should be sort of large so while you
need to go to Infinity probably it works
once this is bigger than some 10 million
but 10 million could depends okay
this is
oh you have some secrets
this
is just ruined can be any sequence which
is uh like uh it's just
something it depends on end it grows
faster
so we need it could be times located
there's no K it's just because of some
concentration results we need we cannot
deal with very response case so K could
be X
music
CD builders
yeah
so what's your name right because you
cannot create
a question the constant and this person
okay
for sure
okay so let me just cook this so we can
we can extend it to the graphene model
we can estimate graphene model it'd be
Minimax optimal this is this is great
for graphing estimation
to have something extract from there
actually it doesn't depend on our macro
to estimation it only depends how well
can you approximate the graph phone by
the way but discretized version so it's
called agnostic hero
uh it's also robust if we don't observe
completely our graph it's robust against
the missing links
and uh it behaves quite nicely in
practice I'm trying for real life data
but people did it before us because
actually we have this variation of this
variational maximum likelihood but this
package is variational maximum
likelihood with slightly different
estimator for for you
so it's so Simone but it's reasonable in
practice
okay so I think I should stop
um thank you so uh
I think it's interesting that in the
sparsity regime where row event is order
one over n
is that this mean field approximator
doesn't work
but that some other variational
approaches do
order one over n which the what the out
term says that the zero estimator will
be Minimax optimal we cannot do better
than just put everything to zero well
there's two regimes I mean there's when
they're it's a sufficiently small
constant times 1 over n depending on the
parameters then yes there's there's
nothing you can do but then there's that
phase transition and above that you can
use things like belief propagation and
there are positive results by masulier
and Michelle Neiman and Sly and so on
so but my so I I think it's interesting
that there is some barrier here around
log n over n
where we go from where somehow the the
posterior
um starts to really diverge from the
product distribution which is
interesting
um but my other question which related
to his is that for for the parameter
learning the you know learning The
Matrix Q
and this is also just experience from
that sparse regime but in the detectable
regime
um there there do often seem to be
multiple
uh Optima that don't have the same
likelihood
so if I understood you correctly not for
two groups by the way but if you have
more than two groups
so for instance if if you have four
groups then sometimes uh a uh gradient
descent in this variational likelihood
can get stuck at a local Optimum which
is not as good as the global Optimum
because it's sort of dividing things the
wrong way so you made a claim that
surprised me which if I understood it
correctly was that all local Optima of
so let's define a function f of Q which
is the maximum of everything else but Q
you said that in that all local Optima
are equally good uh what I'm saying this
is for for the original function now I
don't know how to find the this function
what I'm doing I'm finding an
approximation going with this through
this exploitation maximization algorithm
right I'm not guaranteed to get the
maximum of original function right but
the second step here I use an
approximation to compute the maximum
here I use the quotation maximization
algorithm but there are many other
choices since Lisa has very nice people
on that so when how you optimize it
right my results they are about this
estimator which is computational
principle but the practice
what what we do expectation here what we
use is the expectation maximization and
actually uh probably it goes in the same
direction actually we need to uh like
nice initialization we use Miss is there
to initialize our algorithm and then it
works quite nicely
okay from uh Spectrum yes but then you
might get stuck in this step but all our
results in discussion was about this
estimator because I need to compute it
and then I go through a second like
layer of approximation and did I agree
with we need to initialize nicely and
would all simulations we did we
initialized with Mrs them
mentors to preach well
I guess this is just a remark that maybe
you know you make some identifiability
assumptions under which you know you can
recover what you're trying to recover
maybe under those assumptions all global
global maximizers are closed so that's
possible right maybe that's what your
your algorithm is benefiting from there
are some assumptions on the parameters
which makes the you know model
identifiable yeah but just just remark
so our assumptions the Assumption under
which model is identified right right it
comes from Beacon paper and so on right
maybe that's also what makes the you
know uh the variational approximation to
have a it could have multiple Global
maximizers but all of them are maybe
close so then take anyone that would be
a good estimate
I'm just curious if you've thought about
extending your results to any of the
extensions of the stochastic block model
especially the ones that have a number
of parameters yeah what do we have what
we have is it's called vertical
inequalities so we can prove that if
your graph doesn't come from stochastic
look model then with this this algorithm
what you get the risk will have is
Minimax rate with this web plus the
Oracle part which measure how far away
your original graph is from a stochastic
block model and now
we know but take a large cake we can
well approximate it and so the question
is how large of the cake
right I'm getting more interested in
actually estimating the parameters of
these other more General models rather
than just approximating them well that's
a different question in the community's
random graph model you cannot just
estimate each parameter separately right
because you have one observation for
mineral distribution
can I say about it we need somehow group
them
tell me how how to do it now we have
Oracle inequalities that depends how
well stockadeable model approximate it
will approximately eventually well but
with large plate yeah
so I have related question so first you
have answers that so if instead of a
stochastic block model you have a graph
on you get in addition you say the
Oracle arrow in other words the best L2
error so the best in addition you get
the air which would be the best blast
model approximation your graph from I
assume that the local Arrow don't you
also need something
how fast the graph converges to the
graphene because if you if you don't
have any other assumptions it could be
that the model for the block model we
know it converges in some so how because
in the end now you don't want to
estimate the Matrix
aij you want I mean mij or pij you want
to actually estimate the graph on it for
that that you have to control how near
pij is to the graph what we can say
about the graphene model right so we
want to estimate the graphing function
it's password function and actually it's
quite simple to see from triangle
inequality but we'll have the error
which comes from estimation mathematics
which you know how to deal with and then
we have this part which called the
agnostic hero and you if you if you look
at this part it does not depend on my
method of estimation it's really uh how
well can approximate microphone function
exactly by its discretization I wanted
to know so in addition to the to the
Oracle area we need diagnostic error
yeah but this depends only on the class
of Graphics function yeah it is
so I was just expecting that that you
need it does not depend on estimation
methods I'm aware of a class of Graphics
so now to ask her question in a sort of
more formal way what if you had a degree
corrected stochastic block model and I
only have one parameter I tell you that
its power law with parameter gamma
yeah so now I could ask you so now you
actually it's a well-defined min max
problem and solves a question the
reformulating a question is could you
estimate that
wait don't have results on that but I
think you can right where you look
likelihood and then um
approximation I would expect working
this quite well and I think there are a
lot of work contacts from there yeah
significant results on that we didn't
work on that but
okay so as one of the organizers I want
to finish by thanking all of you to
actually now being willing to stay 15
minutes longer for our beautiful last
talk thank you not only all the speakers
but you as well
[Applause]